et ben mission accomplie c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire l'astronaute québécois
david saint-jacques est de retour sur
terre la capsule soyouz qui le ramenait
avec ses deux coéquipiers s'est posée
dans les steppes du kazakhstan à 22h47
c'est à dire précisément une minute plus
tôt que ce que la nasa avait prévu en
juin sébastien desrosiers qui est à l'
agence spatiale canadienne à longueuil à
sébastien c'est la fin du plus long
séjour en orbite d'un astronaute
canadien c'est à dire six mois c'est ça
après 204 jours en orbite david
saint-jacques est de retour finalement
vous l'avez dit c'est la plus longue
mission pour un astronaute canadien et
ça s'est terminé de belle façon vraiment
une descente réglé au quart de tour
l'engin spatial les flancs noirci par
une rentrée atmosphérique houleuse comme
c'est le cas habituellement s'est posée
dans les steppes du kazakhstan dans un
nuage de poussière
aussitôt des secouristes des médecins
des spécialistes se sont précipités vers
le site d'atterrissage pour extirper de
la capsule les trois astronautes david
saint jacques
sa collègue américaine en déclin et son
collègue russe igor colonna qu'au touche
3 en bonne santé
il faut dire que l'impact a selon
certains témoignages
l'effet d'un accident de voiture et
après tout bien il faut réapprendre à
être un terrien en quelque sorte alors
malaise un peu pour david s'agencer
jacques mais rien d'inquiétant nous dit
on il subit bondé examen médical après
cet atterrissage
et justement sébastien à quelles sont
les prochaines étapes pour david
saint-jacques consentant une longue
réadaptation latin ben voilà de beaux
d'abord au cours des prochaines heures
il va prendre la direction de houston au
texas où il va rejoindre l'équipe de la
nasa parce que c'est là qu'il est basé
où il va être réuni avec les membres de
sa famille et bien sûr sa femme et ses
trois enfants d'abord qu'il verra pour
la première fois en plus de six mois
mais où il va bon pour suivre cette
réadaptation pendant plusieurs semaines
au moins quatre à six semaines
par exemple la pression sanguine n'est
plus là même le choeur pen a poussé le
sens jusqu'au cerveau alors il peut y
avoir un sentiment de déséquilibre
d'étourdissement au retour sur terre
le calcium aussi c'est ce que nous
disaient des astronautes qui étaient ici
ce soir prend un temps avant de se
régénérer la règle de trois si vous
voulez c'est pour un mois passés dans
l'espace ça prend deux mois pour
régénérer le calcium alors il en a davet
et jacques vraisemblablement pour un an
la de réadaptation physique et sais pas
si vous avez suivi cet atterrissage dans
les bureaux de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne à longueuil et à ce qu'il y
avait de la fébrilité dans l'air ce soir
ouais c'est moi qu'on peut se dire quand
la soyouz s'est posé au kazakhstan on a
senti vraiment un soupir de soulagement
collectif parce qu'avais bon des membres
de la famille de david saint-jacques
aussi des employés de l'agencé spatiale
qui était très fière et des invités
spéciaux notamment le metteur en scène
québécois que vous connaissez bien
robert lepage est un comédien françois
bernier
voici ce qu'ils aient danese je connais
david depuis un moment maintenant je
vais rencontrer à moscou pendant qu'il
s'entraînait à moscou puis david venez
voir mon spectacle connaissait mon
oeuvre est maintenu ce livre est venue
passer du temps m'a donné à moscou pour
me paraît un peu puis éventuellement
qu'on fasse des projets donc
on avait sans contact on élabore un
projet de film en fait avec un bidon
pour le moment
tourné des scènes potentiellement qui
sont dans un film et
dans l'espace pour nous donc c'est très
excité les choyer alors un projet qui
sera à surveiller parce que comme nous
le disaient les astronautes qui étaient
ici ce soir et david saint jacques au
cours des dernières semaines
un des objectifs de cette mission
c'était d'inspirer les jeunes parce que
il y en avait ici ce soir à l'agencé
spatiale canadienne et ce sera ce seront
tous les astronautes de demain c'est la
sienne et rosiers à longueuil merci je
vous en prie